Well,
I,
I can probably say the most about
healthcare because that's an area where,
um,
uh,
again,
a devoted in approximately last five or
six years,
it really intensively to kind of try to
understand the puzzle of how healthcare,
um,
and healthcare,
I think we have every opportunity to
truly
transform,
uh,
the value of patient in healthcare if we
actually are able to go back and step
back from the incremental changes to
what we have today and ask ourselves
what would it take for us to create a
dramatically higher value system.
So again,
I've,
I've written a lot,
a lot about this lately and,
and,
and talk about it incessantly now,
but,
but you know,
things like,
you know,
just how you organize care,
uh,
things like how you measure success.
Uh,
these things are very,
very simple,
but you know,
our best guests,
uh,
is that we could get double the value
from the amount of money we're spending
today or we could get pretty much the
same value for half the money were.
I mean,
that's the order of magnitude of the
transformation.
And I'm very optimistic about healthcare
because I now see enough grassroots
bottom up effort and enough belief in
the basic framework of that,
that value is how we,
how we need to think and,
and,
and the patient's perspective is what we
should care about.
That I,
yeah,
I can,
I can see a line of sight to,
to a,
a healthcare system that will be very
proud of and it'll,
it'll lead the world and,
and it'll be affordable.